We Begin this hour with the indictment
of former president Donald Trump a New
York grand jury voted to indict the
former president yesterday now he is
expected to turn himself in to be
arraigned on Tuesday we do not have the
exact charges but we do know this that
they're related to the alleged
falsification of business records in
connection with hush money payments made
to adult film star Stormy Daniels before
the 2016 election Trump has called this
indictment as you know a political
persecution an election interference at
the highest level in history CBS News
legal analyst that's Ricky cleeman joins
us along with our chief political
analyst that's John Dickerson welcome to
you both Ricky welcome back to you John
let's start with you you know the
Democrats say no one is above the law
let's let the process play out
Republicans say that this is just a
Witch Hunt legal Voodoo what do you say
what was your reaction when you heard
are they both right
we don't know because we don't know
what's in the indictment that's my first
reaction was let's wait till we actually
find out what's in the indictment of
course that's a naive thing to say in
American politics right now and that's
my second thought which is that this is
an ex this is an explosive event in a
highly volatile time in American
politics
when you have elections you make laws or
you enforce laws there's a system that's
in place to keep it from getting violent
but when you're in a volatile moment it
can get violent and so everybody has a
responsibility who's in the political
process to either
add fuel or they've got a question not a
responsibility are you adding fuel are
you taking fuel away and what you're
saying in this moment when we don't know
whether the indictment is a strong
indictment or a weak one but I've heard
so many even Democrats say privately
that is this the case we should go after
okay he had a relationship with Stormy
Daniels he may have used money illegally
so what so what who cares who cares what
do you say to that that they said that
there are so many things that are so
much more important than this case it's
up to the prosecutor and we'll see what
the prosecutor did I mean I and we'll
know the problem in American politics is
all this conversation that takes place
in the absence of facts exactly and the
president and his party are doing
something smart which is in the absence
of facts they are rushing in to Define
what this case is about we don't know
Donald Trump doesn't know it's under
seal and the question is after January 6
where we saw what Donald Trump did when
there was an official proceeding that he
didn't like yes when you're in his party
are you adding to this volatility or are
you removing it Kevin McCarthy before
the after the election he said that
Donald Trump won that was a lie then on
January 6 Kevin McCarthy now speaker was
terribly frightened by what happened he
saw what happened when you spoke in
apocalyptic terms how that could play
out so why now is the speaker saying
that this is an effort by the Manhattan
D.A to subvert an election that's
speaking in apocalyptic terms about a
thing you know nothing about you know
nothing about it because the indictment
is sealed why after the history of
January 6 would you as a public figure
add more fuel to the fire isn't your
obligation when the system is as fragile
as it is right now to hold back the fuel
um Ricky speaking of adding fuel to the
fire former president Trump continues
this rhetoric and incites violence at
the courthouse could he be held liable
for that there's always the question
when we go back to January 6th whether
or not the justice department may decide
to hold him liable for that and that
same logic could apply to a future uh
act of violence by a group by the way at
this point in time there is no
intelligence at least according to the
people I speak to that shows that there
will be any kind of violent activity at
the courthouse between now and Tuesday
but it's not only Manhattan that we're
dealing with right we're dealing with
the entire country we're also dealing
with the safety of a particular
prosecutor a courthouse Personnel Donald
Trump himself his safety as well as the
safety of the secret Grand jurors who
may or may not remain secret right so
you have a lot of security issues best
place to try it is New York the NYPD
knows how to handle these things Ricky
uh so you heard Joe takapina talking to
Gail earlier this notion that the
federal government Merrick Garland has
had the same access to the information
that Alvin Bragg has cyvance before
Alvin Bragg had access to this
information the feds have chosen not to
indict why people want to know why did
the feds choose not to indict and thus
why is Alvin Bragg decided what does
Alvin Bragg know that others don't they
didn't well we don't know what Alvin
Bragg knows and if he knows more than
others did or not by the way it has been
well publicized that this case the hush
money Stormy Daniels business records
falsification case in the DA's office by
many people was called the zombie case
it was the case that cyvance did not
want to prosecute for a lot of reasons
including the fact that his novel unique
don't know if it will hold up in a court
of law but also you have Merrick Garland
who perhaps had bigger fish to fry he's
dealing with the January 6th
Insurrection that's a case that if they
do decide to go forward through Jack
Smith his special counsel that really is
directly against the United States of
America and you also have Mar-A-Lago and
the question and obstruction of justice
so in the order of things it seems that
Merrick garland would have been more are
interested in those two cases than in
this case John let's look at the history
I always like talking to you about
history because you are a friggin
encyclopedia we keep saying that this is
unchartered territory never happened
before can he be indicted and still be
elected president what does this look
like what does this mean well yeah he
can be I mean we've had candidates
who've been under indictment who've run
for president they haven't won but
um I believe in 2016 I believe Rick
Perry there was an indictment against
him for a couple of months
um it was waved away quickly or went
away quickly but um yeah he can go
forward end in fact there's just what do
you think John well I think I go back to
I go back to what I started by saying
which is we are in this volatile moment
and leaders have a responsibility to the
moment and to the system if you
participate in a system of making laws
or participating in elections you were a
steward of that system you can't befoul
it and then say Oh wait but have it
apply to me in a clean and pristine way
when I'm participating in it right you
are a steward of it so what is a
Steward's obligation in this case where
we don't really know the facts yet if
the facts come out and it's a weak case
then everybody should say this is a weak
case and there's an there you are
hurting this same system that I've just
been banging on about if it's a strong
case then people should say you know
this is a strong case within a system
where we deal with people and no one is
above the law we just don't know which
of those two things it is so in the
absence of that if you're a steward of
the system treat the system with respect
by withholding judgment until we know
what the facts are if I could just pick
you back on that for a second that also
applies to Alvin Bragg Alvin Bragg is a
steward of the system he believes he has
the facts on the law and he went forward
accordingly this has been a substantive
discussion thank you both very much
Ricky cleeman John Dickerson we
appreciate you